. So this is super important for
us to understand and think about.
We briefly spoke about it on a bonus show last
week. But now that we're closer to these Georgia
Senate runoff elections, let's dove in even
further. There is a contingent of trumpet's
in Georgia who are thinking of boycotting the
special Senate runoff elections and staying home.
Why are they thinking of doing that?
Because they're mad that as they see it,
as Donald Trump has been telling them, the Georgia
Republican governor and secretary, Georgia's
secretary of state, haven't fought hard enough to
give Trump the election, even though Joe Biden won
it. OK, that's even though Joe Biden won and Trump
lost. There are Republicans who are thinking of
boycotting the Senate runoffs because they think.
Brian Kemp and the secretary of state in Georgia,
Brad Raffensperger, should have done more to
steal the election for Donald Trump. That's some
trumpet's. And they're saying boycott the January
5th Senate elections because we want to punish
Georgia Republicans for doing that. Other Trump is
Republicans are thinking of boycotting the January
five Senate election because they believe it's
rigged. And just like it was rigged against Trump,
they believe that they voted for Trump in large
numbers. But because of the rigging they lost,
they likewise believe if we vote on January five,
it also is rigged. So we're going to boycott in
protest. There's two different sides to this
boycott. Now, the Republican Party realizes
that if they keep calling it rigged, they might
inadvertently encourage people not to vote,
which will make them lose both of these
Senate elections, which would be great for us,
but bad for them. So it is rally on Saturday night
in Georgia. Yes, there are rallies and we will
get to clips later. Donald Trump was at the same
time attacking the system in Georgia as rigged,
claiming he really won Georgia, attacking Governor
Brian Kemp, attacking the secretary of state,
but also saying and by the way, we really have to
vote in Georgia, sort of an incoherent message.
If it's all rigged and fake and stolen, why is it
that people should vote? Isn't it going to happen
again now? I received a ton of emails from our
viewers saying, David, you should participate in
this, encourage or start playing up, that it was
rigged to trick and encourage Republicans into not
voting. It would be really great because control
of the Senate is riding on this. You should
encourage Republicans to boycott, get them to stay
home, and then John Joseph and Raphael Warnock
will win. Here's my thought on this. For more than
a decade on this program I've been calling for
and advocating for and encouraging more
civic engagement, which starts with voting.
Everyone should vote has been my perspective
and my mantra for years. I believe in total,
the country is better off with more people having
a stake feeling involved. And and by the way,
I think it's better for the progressive
movement to have higher turnout. Republicans
know that they do better by suppressing the vote.
They have a different view. I don't want that. I
want more voting and I want more engagement.
So it would be immoral for me to now say,
Republicans, you should stay home because it
was rigged, especially when it wasn't rigged,
other than their own voter suppression,
which failed to actually give them the win.
So it would be morally wrong and antithetical
to my beliefs to start encouraging Republican
voters not to vote. Now, that being said, if
Republicans as a strategy want to encourage
their own voters to boycott the election, I'm not
going to get in the way. This is sort of like I
would never wish death on anyone. But I could at
the same time recognize that sometimes the world
is better off with certain people not around. I
would never hope that someone becomes ill or dies,
but I can still feel OK saying this was a bad
person that did bad things were better with
them not doing those things anymore. Similarly, I
believe in voting. I believe in civic engagement.
I believe in participation in democracy. I would
never encourage otherwise. And I recognize if
Republicans are telling Republicans not to vote,
it might lead to Republicans losing the Senate.
And that would be a very good thing for the
country. So I'm not going to get in the way if you
really did believe it was rigged, which it's not
not in favor of Democrats in Georgia. In Georgia,
you have the opposite. You have Republicans who
have purged voter rolls, shut down polling places
and all of that stuff. But if you really believed
it was rigged and that your vote didn't matter,
it follows logically that you might decide to
boycott the election. Now, in the meantime,
let's not be stupid. Let's phone bank. Let's
doorknock safely. Let's register to vote.
Let's request absentee ballots and let's try
to win these two races on January 5th. So we're
going to take a quick break. After the break, I
will have clips for you from yesterday's debate
between Kelly Leffler and Raphael Warnock.
It's wacky. And you can find some of those
clips on our Instagram as well, which
is David Pakman show on Instagram.
Find me on Instagram at David Pakman as well.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.